all right starting up and they're like
in this garbage as hotel that I'm
staying at this [ __ ] is wack
[ __ ] the intercontinental and downtown
our lane yeah [ __ ] this Lobby situation
court in another episode man Hansen
remember podcast Hannibal Burres Tony
trim special guest pick Mensa
yo y'all on the shot I'll keep doing i
ha ha ha tony has a new toy yeah a crazy
mixer we're not gonna say too brand
because we don't want plug they [ __ ] if
they give it a [ __ ] for free that's how
we feel
word up apologies man for last time
that's okay man yeah it was I felt bad
because I was know something like 9 oh
you wouldn't sleep no I was up at 9:00
in the morning holy I hit me up I got
the I got the video crew and everything
I was like nice and I I went to sleep
thinking I need about 20 more minutes
and I woke up is about 11:40 we were
supposed to meet it I know how I know
how it works man I'd be falling asleep
through said man I wasn't even Trevor
yeah I was actually glad I got to go
take my girl to Barney's yeah I was like
I'm a ghost wag out nice but you know I
felt I felt worse because it was my you
know as the when you're when is your
thing you're supposed to be not asleep
you're supposed to be not asleep because
because you imagine if you showed up to
do like Fallon I'm not to say that our
podcast it's not a level but it's the
same thing like he hold it I host like
if the host isn't there that's some
[ __ ] man
but you know I'm sometimes I'm sorry
Jimmy Fallon is sleeping yes and ballad
is sleeping sorry he just standing
outside of 30 rock that's it what
Colbert huh
yeah man I felt I felt but I've been on
have you uh had some some professional
situations before we like uh you showed
up crazy late then you just try to play
it cool and everybody around you have to
play it cool because you know artists so
they can't really mention that they kind
of resent you
oh no you wouldn't what you think make
up for like um koto oh [ __ ] what a [ __ ]
it's alright
your fight through oh oh oh yeah whose
song is that the samples uh the iPhone
wringer few things he knows I don't know
yes somebody has that what that's the
beat don't beat good [ __ ] these on my
line it's time
go [ __ ] I'm gonna Danny's house I'm not
trying to girl and this time I got stuff
done I was willing to do somebody just
I've heard about it but I don't know I
don't know who that is what is that if
he's got a song called love no Dottie's
where he's talking back and forth to a
girl and rap for him yeah she's love no
titles yeah doesn't use like a vocal
processor where he goes back we speaks
as the girl in different voice she's
like why are you acting like you know me
is like cuz you draw a [ __ ] basically
like this is it it's like oh my gosh it
come on
[Music]
love no fatties what's your you and you
in a relationship
yeah yeah what would be will sure did
you have lines when you weren't in the
relationship when you're on single life
good boy if you like best music is good
boy
real simple now I mean it's [ __ ] up
I like have completely lost all
tolerance for like courting processes
and [ __ ] and just like being spoiled
enough to have women know me in
different parts of the world for enough
time that I'm just not even I'm not into
all that other [ __ ] like trying hard and
[ __ ] like that
Thomas oh yeah I'm just not even into
all I said I'm like I just I just leave
or ask her to leave I don't want to do
no lines and nothing like that I don't
yeah I don't want to do anyways I'm just
over that [ __ ] did you ever do they like
the tenders and the bumbles never get it
no you never gotten into there now you
have a I have you I use bumbles
sometimes bump was the one where the
girls have to say the first line and
what I found is that women are terrible
at first lines
I got a bumble you matched with my uh
with my girlfriend's friends on bumble
actually who that her name is Lia
earlier we didn't go out that's funny
the college had some stupid city and I
got out of there that's what it that's
what end of habit they say some stupid
[ __ ] and I so they always say the first
line on that one that's that that's the
rule it was made because I guess it was
made by women because guys on tinder
always say wild I was a day that's right
yeah just gross [ __ ] rotten food you
trying to pull was so it what you want
to see my little [ __ ] you want to put
and so it is you know there's a middle
ground you can't go that crazy and so
this woman created bumble to try to even
the playing field
and so when you match a woman has to say
she has to engage and say the first line
what what are these first lines consist
of I would have thought it would just be
like what up it's mostly what's up it's
mostly honey yours you want to hear my
bumble what first lines that they say
yeah what they say yeah a new segment
new segment I'm a redact man some of the
bumbles give him one give him a segment
thumbs up in the second tune reading
that's what I've read it from my Bombo
what the [ __ ] is going up waiting
reading from my burning bold here's the
latest one this girl she you know my
public appearance schedule is easily
accessible to the least resourceful of
people with internet access so this one
I matched with a while ago we went back
and forth but I was in Atlanta working
and it just wasn't you know and so she
says uh hey are you doing fyf tomorrow
now she knows that I'm doing it
FIF because big anime Moana on the
goddamn poster for fYI I wanted to part
we wanted to say no there's - no I'm not
but I said yes and then she replies
wants a hangout as actual people like
not for sex
oh that's what she said that's what she
fell by god haha what is so weird
that's so weird because okay that's like
what was your reaction ha
oh so weird thing with you
haha not perfect because here we've been
going back and one but haven't travelled
because he/she reengaged off of knowing
where I was going to be was because I
know we're going to say yes yeah no
she's a she's a teacher I know all for
summer teachers get wild in some
teachers wild out in the Sun be cool
yeah hey Wallace here but you know hey
while i was i with know what the like
the baddest teachers I had growing up
was really about outside of the grammar
school classroom yeah yeah I better very
light out all that yeah CPS don't even
drug tester - it is love wow that's why
I'm saying I don't be [ __ ] with that
[ __ ] because it's like it's like first
of all [ __ ] why's you looking for love
anyway on a dating app I don't get it
doesn't seem like the ideal place like
clearly usually trying to highlight
anything you know where I'm at why you
got to be all weirdo like that not like
you come up and I'm like whip up my dick
on you and [ __ ] like right well yes
here's the thing I think it's okay to
for them to look for love on it and I'm
sure some people have found lots of
people have found love on that but I
think for her to reach out to me so you
go bfy up I just say yes let's hang out
like regular people not for sex that
well that was on your mind you went to
that yes he could have just left it at
the regular dude let's say you want to
hang out and now I absolutely do not but
when I you know what when I first heard
a grinder yeah I was like oh [ __ ] this
is like an app for like gay dudes where
there's like they're in the vicinity
there's a guy over there the next block
he's trying to [ __ ] he's trying to [ __ ]
they meet up they [ __ ] like they need to
have an after straight people and it was
tender and it was tender but that's not
what tender is well it I think well I
wasn't on tinder during the beginning
but I think at the beginning that's what
a visitor was that he's all the gliders
do this you know and then now you have
women in their profiles calling
themselves dog moms and saying that
so hookups that's what does go calm now
yeah you went to Whitney Young yeah
what year did you graduate from Whitney
Young yeah I was on going now 2011 [ __ ]
people that don't know Whitney Young is
one of the five good high schools in
Chicago
mhm you got to be smart to get in there
somewhat yeah you have a free smart yeah
be smart where's a handful of schools
the Chicago Public School System is
notoriously underfunded and photoshops
of the schools are treated poorly
Whitney Auguste wanted the beacons of
the city along with Walter Payton oh you
were 20 on I was at a key then they
kicked me out 7 and 8th grade but I
could grow and I was not ready for prime
time so first you go to high school they
just you know what happens what I just
kind of I wasn't
I didn't adjust well I went to a small
private school from K to sixth grade and
then I tested in the Whitney Young and
then kinda I think the scale of going
from this little school where you know
my school is a school st. Paul Lutheran
had two classes in each except for
kindergarten every class had two grades
in the first a 2nd grade 3rd or 4th
grade 56% in it and so that for going
from that Whitney Young when you're in
high school now as a 112 years old with
a big-ass backpack with a big-ass
backpack [ __ ] slapping you back
I used to slap the [ __ ] out of the AK
use backpacks when they were run by
America there but they head down put the
arms back you know just be running down
the hallway trying to make it to class
yeah be like oh just for clarity the AK
use the academic center with the young
will you tested you go there for 7 and
8th grade and you get high school credit
and then you kind of start off if you do
well as a 17 eighth grader you start off
credit wise as a sophomore in your
freshman year so I didn't do well and
then they just when I they graduated
and in the mail I just received a
transfer to my neighborhoods and this
was Stine minutes they didn't say a word
I will meet with you today you go to
stinemans now it was fun having you Wow
yeah I'm so cold-blooded so you went to
stop man went to stinemans yeah how was
that it was all right yes it was you
know it was I used to wish I was at with
you right go to some Whitney Young
dances and [ __ ]
ha ha ha ha cuz my friends were there
and go see my friends hey what's up it's
still some people I probably I mean I
probably talk to more people that I went
to 17 8th grade at Whitney and and I
talked to four people and people to work
you do why because it ain't nobody has
diamonds that probably left that
neighborhood the Whitney Young have like
better girls and stuff too it's just a
lot of my classmates from Whitney Young
lawyers and [ __ ] yeah dot like several
doctors business people I feel like I
didn't hang out with the right people
and with you know I mean I did I hung
out with like but you know the
difference between like the cool kids
and then the kids that actually want to
make something of their licensure so I
went to look in but I don't group and
there is and the other kids are [ __ ]
like I don't know anybody with a job oh
I know nobody that's a lawyer doctor
maybe one doctor pretty much nobody with
a job yeah in Chicago you what was the
art scene like in Whitney Young we are
wrapping the [ __ ] in the hallways and
foot working yes you were working yes
yes my your eyes lit up you like yeah I
don't think I was I expected to get
asked if I was foot working in in the
hallway with you which I definitely
would not that I'm like a skillful
worker but yeah
we were show rapper and he does like us
and we was foot working was beating on
the lockers it was on all up you still
got it
you still got the foot can you just
break it out I'm trying to try to tell
you I can't actually footwork I just was
foot gotcha
I was just acting out my foot working on
tables and [ __ ] da I love it
to music so much it's great and I we DJ
that East Room a couple weeks ago and I
started playing some Juke [ __ ] and you
know it was this white chick off to my
right I hear her somehow in the midst of
this loud as club I hear yelling next
song ah next song yeah I drop the beat
out I say what oh yeah that's right yeah
that's all oh snap down with a book say
what the [ __ ] I forgot about that
you step out yeah I said what the [ __ ]
this is Chicago is the home of Jew [ __ ]
get the [ __ ] out of here if you don't
want to hear that [ __ ] and I snapchat
that and then I proceeded to play like
seven in a row there was everything my
own little working Bobby went in it was
like two or three different foot working
circles going on and positive play so I
was popping yeah you're poppin spiteful
jokes a little Dukes next Oh like I said
you know I'm afraid you were like oh
yeah no spoof on to say [ __ ] to me all
the time that I brush off dog I hear so
much [ __ ] and see so much [ __ ] but that
[ __ ] in the middle of a DJ set in
Chicago like fine I was like I know you
ain't from here yeah
if you from here you from Highland Park
or some [ __ ] like that talking about
that in the Juke say [ __ ] outta guys
like you came to it's ain't even my real
job I'm DJing you should be happy
yeah I even a diesel something able to
DJ and we had the theremin and we had
the [ __ ] vocal processor we were
going in we did the whole [ __ ]
Angermann actually do it says it's just
you know you got to is it on
value maybe let me see when way north on
this is if you know the turbine does it
is the heart of this podcast because we
end up explaining it to uh every guest
but it's just you know different
different tunes and [ __ ] yeah man try to
keep [ __ ] loose I've been watching some
of your other interviews you can see
them intense watch but yeah you know I
watched a couple interviews and I'm not
talking about that work but it was a
cover when you just seemed I know doing
press is exhausted but I received
you've been intensity you should in the
past I've been intense like I know Vicki
more chill than that yeah I think I
showed I show what I else in that video
Oh is giving you you know I need to meet
when I had nothing man he's always
across the street man you come to kill
word uh but you know about the academics
I didn't know about that
chiraq video series mmm it's not watch
youto like 500 videos on this here's 500
yeah yeah it was yet a tone of it I
think is yeah I don't think here he is
intent was malicious but I definitely
see how people like a [ __ ] this dude
look cuz I was watching them like down
because it has this real weird kind of
chipper tone about murder like this guy
did this Iraq Savage is out I've not
killed it's not like you imagine
somebody was on the news talking about
murder to look at again this guy got
[ __ ] killed knee comes to blaster
with the blame okay that's how he kind
of the tone is blaster winces well
because this guy come
my god a machete midnight it's the tone
the tunnel you ready right yeah that's
hard I just felt like um you know in no
other situation no other war situation
would there be like a comical series
reporting it like imagine there was like
a running joke on CNN about the war in
Syria you mean it's just like and they
kill that al Baghdadi's stupid ass today
and is upside initially like you know
it's just like it wouldn't happen it's I
can't think of any time that there's
like a comparable a comparable situation
to that where there's like a running
joke about a real life death situation
you know real life war with constant
casualties there's no other example of a
[ __ ] just having a continuous
joke about something like right yeah
it's upset and so and it's it is it was
tough man is when I when I travel and
and I'm sure you've experienced the same
and we people know you from Chicago say
you from Chicago who I'm scared to I
don't want to how'd you do it and [ __ ]
it's like oh that's just uh it's tough
to take all you see and so people try to
make it a surface level thing when it's
just deep is deep-rooted stuff with you
know just a side of racism and you know
funding and jobs and [ __ ] now I don't
just try to think of how to help this
way I can't just walk into the hood with
hey stop shooting [ __ ] anyway
is that to do from he live a even
vaguely familiar family nobody you can't
just walk up in the middle of [ __ ] and
just say shut it down yeah
what do you do that's what Trump said
right he said we're going there we're
going to take care of this
yeah what was the plan sounded he
doesn't believe found out what was its
plan did he have a plan is missing
National Guard ever stuff like that
he's just in deep than just be talking
man yeah and if you really need to focus
on collaborative the other stupid [ __ ]
that he's trying to do yeah I mean he
doesn't have the first clue about what
to do in Chicago you know I was
listening to some others in the Malcolm
Gladwell's podcast the other day about
rich people golf and they said that it
was some crazy stat but they said that
like Trump has played more golf since
his first they have offers then like
Obama during his whole presidency
remember when shrimp was trippin about
saying Obama was playing golf to my
family this my burger player has played
more golf than Obama's whole presidency
yeah
how about about this my father play more
golf than me too and I ain't even
president how about that how about if
you the president don't play no [ __ ]
golf I ain't even playin golf yes sure
I'm out here podcaster was you've had
some have you had any travel troubles
lately not lately man I mean I got
kicked off a bunch of flights left here
a bunch how many flights like maybe
three I'm sorry about one about gone
flight I saw one you were talking on the
phone with a fan that was going through
something yeah man so I was talking on
the phone to this kid he was like all
suicidal and all these things it was
like it was my birthday I think and he
was like on Instagram like you know
please if you call me make my life you
know and I called them I was in the
first class get you love block your
number everything you just called him
straight up I just called him straight
up fake ministers for the people so I
called him and I'm talking to him and
you know keep him on the plane hasn't
started roll into anything yet but you
know the lady lady came by one time she
told me to put the phone away I'm like I
four so I didn't do it
she came back she said put the phone
away so I'm like I broke I'm about to UM
I'm telling him bro I'm some little kid
I'm talking to him like yo I gotta go
you know these people are tripping but
be safe you let me take care of yourself
don't do nothing crazy and then I'm
putting the phone away and like as I'm
getting off the phone a lady comes back
one last time she sees me still with the
phone in my hand and she was like did
like that I was like what the [ __ ] is
going on here she did the one finger
across the throat in tell me like imma
kill you type vibe Wow ng Python I
chilled right then I don't say no and
then um and then they said to Center
[ __ ] like police or whatever on to
the onto the plane way to remove me oh
and all types of [ __ ] I might have
turned up at that point I probably did
and got on so [ __ ] the police [ __ ] and
all that
I don't even remember which one this was
this was probably this was United now I
fly United all the time because I got
banned from American band because I got
kicked off the United flight then I went
you know got another flight whatever
another time American uh what happened
with them oh so basically the flight was
five hours late you know I'm with mad
people
everybody's pressed you know how it goes
when the [ __ ] starts to and they keep
pushing back the time thirty minutes
yeah every 30 minutes they're like it's
going to be here then and they pushed it
back for literally five hours and
finally we're getting on the [ __ ]
flight phones are dead um everybody's
pressed I had like some premiere or
something some type of [ __ ] and so he
calls one of the groups that sounds the
same as mine it was like there's like
platinum premiere and then there's just
platinum or some [ __ ] you know so he
called something that I misinterpreted
it was probably the group right before
mine so I went I walk up and show to my
[ __ ] he was like he was very
disrespectful he was like I didn't call
your group go to the back and but I
didn't even I didn't
trip you know me I just I was like
[ __ ] I'm just trying to get the [ __ ]
out of here I walk off and then when my
group is when it's my groups turn to
come I'm walking up and and I guess
another lady was kind of in the same
situation that I had been in and then he
was treating her and he was just like
had his hand in her face you know I mean
telling her how she had the
[ __ ] get out of the line and go
to the back I was a small woman you know
and so that just turned up on him you
know I mean I was like I you know you
just already treated me foul well now
that was affecting this woman you have a
pattern of abuse and the plight of our
hey y'all a bomb I was late like you
should be accommodating to us yeah so I
just didn't give him a moment to speak
and I ain't even cursed I was pretty
eloquent I just treated him and [ __ ]
disrespected his weight and things like
that and then and then he was like he
was like well I could go get out of line
with her too and basically I was just
like [ __ ] out of here [ __ ] and I just
scared my own ticket and got on the
flight oh yeah and they're not gonna
respect that yeah uh you know so I got
kicked off band still be [ __ ] my [ __ ]
up and I'm not good I'm not good with
airports man I'm not good with powered
power trips I feel like the airport is a
major place like if I have like somebody
that's on my team like management or an
assistant or something I'll be straight
but when I'm dolo I'm just not good with
the airport because it's such a power
trip and it's like they know that they
have the power to I can't walk
you know me I can't walk to New York so
I need the [ __ ] airline so that they
abused their power do what they did to
that Asian man I was so glad to see like
not because the you know that asian dude
got beat up by airport security or that
the you know what I'm talking about when
they dragged him off and all it was like
all these airport things started
dropping in like a couple weeks I was so
glad to see it because I was like I try
to tell you I'm not [ __ ] crazy these
air [ __ ] line Airport
people are crazy and maybe trying to act
crazy with me and then I turned up on
them and then I get kicked off and
banned you put yeah yeah you put
somebody in a position of power
especially when you're starting to talk
about like the threat level is Amber
Alerts right we're really taking this
serious when you take it over there and
like right they say whatever like you
sneezed you out of here it's [ __ ] up
because sometimes my travel plans still
be messed up
because I just can't take American and
I'm like you [ __ ] it was yo
[ __ ] fault I know I took it a
little bit far but like the woman who
got who uh you know whose honor I was
basically defending she ended up working
it like sure microphones and sent us a
bunch of free [ __ ] cuz oh [ __ ] cuz I
wasn't crazy yeah this [ __ ] was just
out of his body but you know and
everybody listening tweet and Instagram
American Airlines and tell them let
Vincent I'm on let vic mensa back on
autumn back on that's the thing airlines
no to because you see like you'll see
something happen where airline and
people say I'm boycotting this airline
you can't if you entertain a traveler
you can't boycott the big ones you got
to get someone you can boycott like
frontier boycott like rancheros but yeah
you can't boycott if you are for real
traveling entertainer
you cannot boycott American Delta as
very United or what's the other that's
it right
those three uh Southwest not your
boycott soft but solid but a man less is
solid though yeah what if they don't
even be acting out but yeah you can't
with you can't I can't just be like [ __ ]
delta airlines like Delta Airlines well
how you getting the Tallahassee oh yeah
I guess I guess Tallahassee is a delta
City I guess I'll be uh you know but
glandular check it out sir yeah you know
like you know you had a bit where you
were talking about oh I don't know if
it's a bitter if we just had this in
conversation but you talk about how
every person got their own personality
like they would be like you go to TSA
and like take off your hat or take off
your glass or something but it's just
super chill like oh yeah welcome you
know here at all like the arbitrary
aspect of TSA [ __ ] where this is a
government agency and it's travel every
time that's the constant you're a
government person it should be the same
[ __ ] but you have some TSA people they
look at your boarding pass right where
you going is right there
or their ads when I order you wish
birthday it's right or take off your
glass I know like I don't want to be
going off of your subjects that they're
looking would actually have their
systems right in place because if you're
[ __ ] whenever you veer off the course
I might get infuriated because I'm used
to something else yeah somebody might
just never the bag hell is this it's
like there's no uniform system in the
airports either so it's like half the
time they'll say you got to take a
tablet or a [ __ ] iPad out your bag
then another half I might take the iPad
out my bag put in the bin and be like I
didn't say iPads I'm like damn how am I
supposed to know man like y'all keep
switching the [ __ ] rules Trump will
get three weeks of goodwill if you just
said a that hold water [ __ ] we done with
that you can bring your waters be like
okay let's see what Trump talking about
let's see what he guess where he get two
weeks or like Joe that was like yeah
movin my her stuff is trying to get is
trying to win favor major favor by
legalizing marijuana I don't know if
there's what there is to that but with
somebody mentioned that to me I was like
they might as well I hope they do he's
armed any money he's looking at the
money you look access is the money so I
would worry I don't want him to be the
one no because black if Trump legalized
marijuana so many people would just
overlook all of the horrible things he
said and done and be like
by the irony yeah the irony of he's
gonna legalize marijuana he's the one
that legalizes the same-sex marriage
across the country he's doing that you
know I'm saying goes super left that the
irony of that would be crazy
sadly so unfortunate there would be no
accountability right to have it just for
one reason Atlanta I had a friend in
Atlanta that recommended me to this we
got and I hit him up and said Amen I
need about an eighth of some [ __ ] that
won't make me paranoid and he said I'd
I'm on my way
animal [ __ ] never showed up
never not even like a text or like I
feel I'm not making it I wait because he
was about because I was waiting on
another friend tutor just to meet up a
little go heat and go hang out she was
it took her about an hour and a half and
I called them right around the same time
so I'm like okay maybe you know the
[ __ ] in Atlanta they move slow so an
hour and a half yeah she's gonna come
through the we to be here it's gonna be
a good she came through and the we guy
was didn't hear from him I need legal
weed so I've heard I've got a bad
[ __ ] I've heard bad things about
people trying to get weed in Atlanta
like one of my managers is like very
stingy will we so all my friends have
kind of like gotten to a point where
they don't even really want to ask him
for know we like I still might they
don't really want to ask him because he
might give you a little like or or like
be like I don't have enough like I got
it yeah he's that guy but um so they're
my cousin man he was on tour with me in
Atlanta and I guess he was like with
some girls or something he just was
trying to get the weed he wasn't trying
to deal with it you feel me so he went
to where the weed was supposed to be at
and I mean he ended up getting the weed
but he went into a whole Trap House yeah
like it's boarded up it's [ __ ] in
there with guns and [ __ ] I'm like so
stupid ass maybe you go go all the way
into a trap house in the hood for some
weed why we need legal marijuana
like we need it man this is so dangerous
for no reason yes in Denver doc right I
was at a 3-week in Denver but it's
forget the name of the spot it's a
black-owned dispensary to be able to a
black-owned dispensary i go to a lot of
like oh this person he responds it's
just like you look at [ __ ] get your weed
pills get the cific products didn't have
a conversation hey I'm very neurotic and
but I like to be high get me that [ __ ]
so I could be high but I won't think
everybody's trying to murder me so then
what do you what kind of weird do you
like to smoke just uh what was that
strain it I really [ __ ] with because I
get some [ __ ] I remember that was the
grimace is some [ __ ] I'll smoke again
Revis and Luke rivers how do you know
that him grimace GRI MMAC
God but here's the thing okay I was a
cub here's the thing about revenge let
him indica what's the indica but here's
okay and because is what he likes to
make him not that's the thing though
like weed these days every strain is so
hybrid yeah and cross that like you
can't really like that whole indica
sativa thing is so arbitrary nighttime
really that's outdated everything is a
hybrid now yeah everything so now it's
all about body chemistry is like you
find your strain and you stick with your
strain like blue dream makes me feel a
certain way might not make this guy feel
that way but it makes you feel that way
so you find your strength you stick with
your strain and that's why dispensaries
are important so there's the consistency
of finding that strain and you stick
with it because there's been many times
where someone's like this is an indica
it's going to knock you out I smoked it
My Mind's in circles I can't get no
sleep vice versa Florida y'all need to
find the right strain everybody does
dealing with the adverse effects of some
weed I smoked two nights ago two gave me
major anxiety for the next day exactly
age I was trying to meditate and [ __ ]
yeah I'm like going through this weird
thing I think aliens I really for a
moment felt like aliens landed and I
didn't want to open my eyes because I
was we're kind of
err wait let's back up how aliens just
recently landed you were in that kind of
high mode well so look I was trying to
meditate because I started doing this
Transcendental Meditation and this was
like the first day you're supposed to do
it in the morning and at night and then
I'm ready to go to sleep and I realize
you know
well actually I'm still high as hell but
it's like 2:00 a.m. I want to go to
sleep it's like maybe 3:00 a.m. I'm
trying to go to sleep I got to do this
meditation I did the meditation I was
meditating outside and my boys crib on
Laurel Canyon I was sorry to walk me
through Transcendental Meditation cuz I
know a couple people that swear by it
but I just well I just got internal man
I just got in tune it was like brought
to America by a guru named Maharishi and
basically it seems very similar to forms
of meditation I've done in the past but
there's like a mantra and everybody gets
their own mantra when they get like
initiated into it and then you just
meditate and you focus on your mantra
and that's David Lynch's mother he
swears by that [ __ ] work so you're on
you're on the Laurel Canyon I'm trying
to meditate man I'm outside I'm sitting
up on the chair and my meditation pose
um and I start hearing things you know
and just like sounds like a footstep and
then I'm kind of scared it's really late
I'm really high I hear what sounds like
footsteps I keep hearing them though it
sounds like I don't know if you have
meditated but a lot of times when I'm
meditating I feel like I'll hear
something that sounds like somebody
entering the room but it might not
really be and I'm trying to stay focused
so I don't want to open my eyes and look
so that's what's going on there and I
kept feeling like I'm hearing footsteps
of somebody coming close to me and then
I saw like just it felt like when your
eyes are closed somebody shines a light
on your eyes only on my right Idol so I
was just feeling like there was aliens
out there and it was shining a
flashlight on my on my right eye
wait you were a higher man aren't you
not supposed to be high when you
meditate
I don't know I just started okay I
didn't get those rules I did I did
somebody that you decide to pick it up
with is somebody suggested to you
somebody suggested it something yeah
they saying you need to relax
sister Berthe I had a girl say that to
me after it was a night of chaos is she
saying you need to meditate negative I
mean I was like I'll mess with
meditation a lot of times in my life it
works yeah I love meditation but it's
just like I was trying to find when it
was suggested to me I was like let me
rock with it because I always I just
want to find a practice something that
like I felt like I could keep going with
like I'm always whenever I feel like
meditating I'm always going off of
something and I probably learned in like
high school you know and just like
without my watered down version of what
I remember so I was like let me read up
on my meditation not to mention it
should be crazy over here just just to
clear your mind reset breathe is that
one of your lyrics right breathe breathe
cuz it's all in your head horn it just
can't happen especially ever on it don't
let me make you imagine we breathe the
sauna you know these labels want to sign
before our middle name that's my life
yeah that was awful orange soda yeah ah
Brielle read because it's all in your
head
no no no meditations real a fungal
matter they they it resets your brain it
uh you turn all your devices off
electricity gets shut off said levitate
a lot I used to meditate now more when I
was doing like kung fu regularly because
they would make us meditate before we
fight because all that anger and stuff
we have to let all that go before you
fight because if you bring that into the
sparring or training if you're very
aggressive and you're aggressive you're
not a good fighter now so if you're calm
in a tense situation you can whoop some
ass yeah so the teachers to keep it cool
before it knock somebody out will you
compare you
and confu now just I'm practicing wing
chun yeah just yeah how long as you do
it why did praying mantis kung fu for
about three four years and then I've
been taking wing chun not the same so
but i'm almost said about a decade now i
need to get back on my martial arts when
i think I'm gonna do a like MMA yeah I
did I did a Korean martial art call you
talked about this yeah in 10 years or
something like that about 10 years that
[ __ ] is real as [ __ ] I saw videos of
that stuff on YouTube yeah I did I did
it for a long time and then I I quit
when I was in high school probably
because I was like trying to smoke weed
and hang out with girls and also my
karate teacher
he got whooped man and I was like in the
streets
yes what by some unconnected he got
whooped man he was like like a million
meeting he I think was like some bikers
or something he's like that's not a good
look I know he's like he's a Pittsburgh
when were away we had it we details
yeah yeah we had yeah details yes from
Pittsburgh man was it did he get jumped
it here's what it was more than one
person but he's from Pittsburgh so he
was wearing a Steelers hat and he was
like probably watching no it's gaga
sorry Cleveland forget Cleveland they
hate each other they like I talked about
Cleveland when I'm in Pittsburgh maybe
like boo y'all are pretty much the same
survey who know I didn't even know they
had a beach there so red Minnesota
Wisconsin a coma no nothing right
everybody here's all the same thing
y'all [ __ ] bring together this
together let's all just make one city
out of y'all wreck
nobody yah success United not match
enough anyways Thomas Jim so you have
sailor shadow man he was in the u.s.
still has had on he was in them like a
sports bar somewhere and it must have
been a Bears game or some I don't know
and then some bikers they whooped a
million I think he fell down the stairs
he came back to karate he had a black
guy and all types of [ __ ] and this is
right around the time I'm like I'm 15
like kind of starting to get into actual
fights yeah I mean like our industry and
nobody I ain't got time for this like
nobody spot squads up with this sparring
thing you know yeah like it just didn't
feel very applicable to me to real life
but then I did end up using karate in
some fights and I'm very glad that I did
martial arts but when I was 15
you know teacher got whooped ain't
nobody trying to karate fight with me
when we get into a fight outside but now
I'm just like [ __ ] this mom here's the
thing that's one thing that I've learned
from hearing that is that no substitute
teachers in karate wait wait did he tell
you that how did you find out did he
tell you that he know I got my ass
kicked
yeah like he should have just kept that
a secret like you see the other guy
well I think you know that's the move I
would've been here okay it was all
credibility once you get Jasmine a
karate boom yeah you can't I know that's
my guy - I got love for but when that
happy man oh well here's matter cause a
little thing I think it might have been
I think it might have been you know a
lesson that you guys were too immature
to receive anybody could lose a fight
okay so like you know respect your
opponent be humble be humble versus
opponent no matter who they are even I
can give and get whoa and whoa that's
one thing that my teacher taught me no
matter how tough were how strong you
think you are there's only always
somebody out there now here's teacher
though his teacher the master master Kim
yeah he ain't getting what you wouldn't
get I couldn't see him getting whipped
by anybody matches Kim was already like
75 years old by the time I learned
another time I yeah yeah by the time I
met master Kim Master Kim thought Bruce
Lee I guess he did get beat by Bruce Lee
but he fought Bruce Lee you know me
master Kim with the truth at
seventy-five years old like doing high
ass flying kicks and breaking [ __ ] man
uh it ended but on the op
to decide I remember my praying mantis
teacher he was because we had high
ceilings in our in our in our studio and
he went to the top of the lino as the
ladders that fold in he goes all the top
of the ladder and he's on the screw in a
light bulb
and he loses his balance a little bit
swear to god this [ __ ] like
he's like always about to fall we're all
like oh [ __ ]
jumps all over the top of the ladder
lands on his feet like a [ __ ] cat and
was just like whoo that was a close one
and we were all just like the others do
this [ __ ] he's from there the truth
he's for real like to just I mean this
guy's like in his 50s and he just did I
fall like that no no no bruised heels
nothing nothing or you know I've been
doing you if you've been to this
festival especially out here FIF s LA
and I've been having this little
overpriced candies there for them in my
goddamn tequila orange juice and then
eating the candies well that's why I've
never [ __ ] your face pastor [ __ ] you FS
actually [ __ ] you FS you got to stay
with the creepy void here say like like
yeah say like this [ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you first but yeah are you [ __ ] Bruce
like what y'all be no you be wrapping
this [ __ ] right we have it you be rapid
[ __ ] right really you're less woman I
was just with my girl two other day and
then I realized when this dude this dude
was like and people said it to me
time these words exactly like I might
meet them and talk to him for a second
and then right as I'm you know about to
make my way they'd be like ear bro I'll
be wrapping this [ __ ] - I told my girl I
was like you that's something that
that's the one thing I hear that nothing
good has ever come from I've never found
out about anything I wanted to know from
when a [ __ ] said I'll be wrapping this
[ __ ] - it really like yeah bro cuz I be
rapid it yeah or do you find it out when
people ask me like so what do you do for
a living and you you like and they don't
know who you are as a rapper and and
then do you find it awkward to be like
I'm a rapper do you say I'm an artist
what do you say I'm a musician or a
writer or do you just say I got a fan so
I'm sorry so you know never make up fake
jobs hmm well yeah sometimes I would
like an accountant I said that they
won't believe you make up what do you do
you have to get deep into the story
because I got I know friends that love
the light just for just because they
don't want to say that they're a
comedian because that leads to fellow
Joba [ __ ] and Lee Ann Arbor's
conversation so they just get into a
whole backstory do you get that deep
into it
so sometimes I make up a lab realize to
people that I don't know because like
what's the stakes yeah where does is way
more fun for so yeah he brought
yesterday night when we performed this
[ __ ] brought out in the posture
for the intro fun [ __ ]
you chose I've do measured anybody take
it with you for a second all those
people boo and I heard some boos yeah I
was a boom yeah cuz I did it for the
spider-man for me I'm just tryna I
didn't I think that's better for us but
all for you I'm a spider-man priam I
need to go see this yeah quick couple
quick lightning get in there all right
fire man it's really good it's good and
that's not me saying cuz I'm minute is
actually good I enjoyed it I'm only
enough about
have some fun movie good energy Tom
Holly's got a good Rotten Tomatoes radio
man got a good ride too man
girls strip has a good ride tomatoes
rails trip with her that's uh Tiffany
Haddish Queen Latifah Regina King really
oh yeah had to know I can't imagine a
Queen Latifah movie having a good run
tomatoes race it's about 92
well what about juice she was in juice
remember that's pre-ride tomatoes and
that was equality so gelareh platter was
we Latifah she was a wonder for a lot of
people but I was associate her with
really bad movies though she was on that
call [ __ ] Omar as a Gumby ass lookin
[ __ ] remember when he came with
his demo tapes and he's like [ __ ] you
she was I [ __ ] you
you Gumby ass lookin you don't remember
that am i my name is Dunkirk Jews Jews
changed my life juice made me want a DJ
that's why I DJ now is because of juice
you ever seen juice Leslie are you too
young for that [ __ ] we gotta steer this
steer this talk I mean maybe you know
maybe we put in some songs with the [ __ ]
we like we didn't talk about music but
here's five big song that I think a dope
trying to do it Spotify said all right
the hell is this we used to talk about
random [ __ ] is what let's talk about
your new album all this not wanna yeah
the new album is uh coming out 228 yeah
coming out on Friday yeah oh [ __ ]
we don't drop this on Friday oh [ __ ] we
don't drop this a data
one thing is propria listen that I've
appreciate is just the range of types of
songs that have been great songs you ate
from you know the [ __ ] off Internet tape
with on soda Hollywood Los Angeles
holy-holy into down on my luck when I
could down on my luck I buy my Hollywood
to saying what's Nobles you knows you
need to know wanna know no one when I
get down on one of the road went up and
rode around Obama local rock music just
no normal Fela voters in the shotgun
which is a totally different sound and
so you man
oh oh she got me mad right that's bad
right wanna catch that cab ride safe bag
that bag right I guess this teachers
don't go [ __ ] herself their purse at
first I guess this needs no ghost white
by herself learn oh now it's uh uh
working with Thundercat of all that was
crazy you know so left feel like because
it's like I didn't even realize
Thundercat was on that saw until I'm
like the song is very machetes my guy
[Music]
where you wanna cook
so I see your flex election and I'm
coming back soon Thundercats a man and I
was very happy to fight I was like
because this is the weirdest song on the
album and then it says featuring
Thundercat I was like oh that makes
sense
I was a the when we were supposed to
interview the u2 in Chicago the day
before I was listening to I was riding
around prepping and listening so there's
a lot going on and then I remembered
when I 24 June 2014
grandpa genius and New York City on my
first day June 6 2014
I had that first Mena Widow plus I
brought out the whole team I drank that
whole bottle of booze sad tight I gave
me that night when we got the club back
the rap genius tells me a shorty got
into a fight it you came out the room
swing you're hitting me in a joke and I
remember oh I'll let that party that's
crazy remember that you were that
everywhere there that night I remember
the first time I heard that she's a
[ __ ] jeans part of my rap song about
that night will be very different
you want to a quick freestyle yeah we're
to the rap G's house it was pretty chill
hung out with Vic Mensa will miles
everybody was kicking it yeah then I
left went to the crib woke up hungover
not a song though yep
all right at the top cause I'm older I
was warming up my story and way less
well so time
let me let me let me yeah there you go
there you go
he's a waiting Vic miss on the beat
there you go
I like this pamphlet because the buttons
are snappy there's no velocity so every
time you hit the drum it goes all the
way oh so like you know when you hit the
pad light yeah I know tonight and I
loaded up all my favourite drums on
there oh did you produce anything on it
oh yeah I did produce some stuff off the
new album umm I produced a record called
rage this out now is on a shorter
project I put out about a month ago
produced that with Mike Dean but in a
burning boat running oh not a soul who
can oh is that the man was sweating
burning ashes from the road I'll put on
the winters the light of the truck just
I'm a mouth or two is really not a dump
[ __ ] you Tom how many thousand such if
you don't like to have money without a
clue by the sound I'll get my like that
Tom I'm tired of waiting you're tired of
chasing girls that I'm trying to take
inside court cases reach on the judges
you try to stand possible and I produced
a record call homewrecker on album dance
to fight the enter home rector who to
episode to be to fight the Idaho
[Music]
I knew you was crazy I knew you was
crazy but goddamn who the effort are we
taking this party we like to get drunk
and get this dog for this dog hot chicks
are ringing everybody on the wall
leaning on a [ __ ] like a attitude with
drop it's just a lot of stories man it
really kind of like takes it takes its
thread of of direction from there's a
lot going on because I made there's a
lot going on well I was writing this out
and I made it as like the current piece
for a year ago that I could put out to
have some music in the marketplace and
well I continue to write this album and
finish this larger longer story
basically that narrative styling just
like really vulnerable honest lyricism
is the connecting piece of this album so
it's like a lot of things that people
that do know me might be like oh wow
that's what happened that time you know
the same waiters who were like damn I
was at that oh yeah I like a girl that
is poppin on his own but if somebody
else-- him that know me might be like
damn I saw him that day yeah I'm about
about things on a new album or like you
know yeah I didn't know that's how it
went down oh yeah I didn't know it all I
was like oh it's been pretty chills good
to see Vic here's a good mood will miles
was that Clark zones mr. miles that's my
man shout-out to mr. mouths man was will
miles your teacher will miles was like a
young student teacher something yeah him
oh yeah I saw something on Instagram
about he was like in the he was in the
building basically he would be there at
lunch that's and like recess he was like
in the lunchroom his mom's worked in the
office right so I was always with his
mom's because I was always getting sent
to the office yeah and then he was in
the lunchroom while we were kicking it
and I be
freestyling and [ __ ] and uh he denied
you be like you got something kid
yeah it was cool it was cool he was
probably about like IIT was probably
like 22 or something right yeah I mean
he was it was what season he's probably
about 32 now right about my I think it's
around my I'm 34 so yeah it was
something like that you know I mean so
he was just in a lunchroom and he was
cool I remember we'd go up and like have
a [ __ ] food fight a some [ __ ] and just
be turning up and nothing too bad what
happened cuz mr. miles was just super
cool if I started on there I am hungover
yeah that's funny I can I can imagine my
guy he's one of the first people to tell
me what to Whitney on and maybe when I
go to wouldn't you alright I can imagine
a mile saying to you like you know you
got some you could rappin and you've
been like you funny you could be a
community that's not like this kind of
exchange you know yeah like a fudge a TV
movie yeah where the the teacher impact
inspires the student and the student
inspires the teacher the new addition
but yeah shout-out to will miles
Clark Jones can you deport they host uh
knitting factory off Sinai Robert Clark
Jones yeah man
rock with Clark Jones man I think I got
up on Clark Jones when we were doing
that uh was like Thanksgiving one year
or some I was about to talk about that
that we did that last minute pop up ed
uh yeah we did a show at tonic
aeronautic rooms that would we go yeah
Thanksgiving Day and I reached out
saying you want to come through I'm
doing I think Clark I forget who else
did it Tony you would DJ and said let's
do a last-minute show just because I
appreciate the holidays but at some
point the [ __ ] needs to stop and you
guys I'm not going to get away from you
fabulous driving impatient you have
really like wide everything close like
and then it's also like if you're not
from Chicago
yeah then if you're not from the city
that you're in and you have nothing to
do on holidays like when I'm in LA on a
holiday it's like I ain't got [ __ ] to
doing a holiday I'm not really I don't
have enough close friends that I want to
do a friend's giving us some [ __ ] right
so yeah we did that a last minute show
atonic room which I've done a lot of
they've been very welcome when I do
pop-up shows there so I hit up a couple
comics including Clark hit a big what
about 80 people there or something like
that it's funny man is packed it was fun
is like a variety show because you did a
set at the beginning of something or you
get a little pop you did a good song the
two did some comedy
you came back up how's the chili yeah
what's your favorite Chicago venues mmm
man I think maybe my favorite Chicago
venue I mean it's probably the metro
yeah thanks extra magenta only get the
superior like oh yeah Joe who owns the
Metro is really cool I feel like a lot
of the people that work at the Metro or
like often gigs but the owner is really
cool the venue is really good the sound
is great you know I think the the
general layout you know for like people
watching is dope because you could be
down like they have a full place they
could get rowdy than the upstairs with
you you know all sighs yeah I rock with
the Metro that's nice everyone good
goodness because you you can't say to
Vic that's weird
I like the big bearded I'm about to do
I'm diggin some what's up with a big
theater it should be mine I might need
me just by the victor of it amen that
might be a great movie I know Rick is
the Vic is Vic it to Vic I like that you
should you should do a live album there
I definitely did Vic it to pick a couple
times yeah it's a guy like because it's
kind of grimy but it's a Rick spot yeah
the biggest dope we did that show
I remember my favorite show I did I
failed my second special day it was a
fun time
oh yes Rick yeah but uh yeah you uh guru
when you talk about somebody on the
record
you know why you talking about somebody
in the rack on a record and it's
personal you have a say hey about to
talk about you on this record
okay or do you say and talk about you on
the project
it won't work all total votes also yes
you know what I'm saying like oh yeah
room or what yeah cuz the people cause
the general public don't know what about
30 people really know 30 people I
gallery is messed up boo true oh [ __ ] up
walking it's a way I feel like what my
boss was like doing little bit before
world was like this what it was before
where the [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] pull up on
attract women boost let it go giggle
dream up yeah that is the effect it kind
of carries your energy right you to be
food Riggle psyllid don't bottoms up
yeah where do you record down on my love
your score drew in Chicago mmm was it
right after the club did you just come
from the Groundhog Day club where I'm a
coffee like yo rose for the girls a CRC
right now also the door tool with the
group called disclose oh yeah
I was like man so let's make some let's
make some stupid face hands and [ __ ]
with that's very uh smart extruder
perfect what we wrote of hope and then
[ __ ] up a hit was born well cool with
the Barker was that the first kind of
because that was that was getting heavy
radio for that hit did it hit first in
the UK mm-hm
we put that out in the UK in Monday
let's get Oakland [ __ ] what smooth man
all right what the [ __ ] because it had
too little Chicago House vibe I went I
used to go to this joint is right across
from Joe's on we Street it might be a
little bit before your time was a house
but god damn it right along we Street ah
but they used to have a house night and
I just like to edit down even cuz the
house this I like house sometime like
house music yeah I don't like how you
supposed to dance the house music oh how
about how you supposed to go it's like
the [ __ ] oh what's that look pretty
good [ __ ] running man that's it looks
pretty tight though that's it looks dope
I mean you will get on there well I
guess I'm ready for the festival I'm
ready for FY yes Lord up you definitely
wrote a miracle doodles from straight up
wait up do you uh or just all cute this
will we ask every musician a rapper on
the show these lucky all music did you
just look in the camera like that
that was a subliminal yes
[Laughter]
I did one one uh one year when I was
somewhere else
um it was [ __ ] up man I think I was
[ __ ] [ __ ] to like or women I'm
sorry god
I was asked to them and it was the guy
I've got as a layer got his God as a
woman yeah I was like a girl too young
bug to cup stuffed Wow I've been to cup
stuff oh my gosh that was like anybody
this down for that is just like doesn't
really give a [ __ ] I like having sex the
Travis Scott music I decided it's good
sex music I had a threesome
the latest playboy cardi tape oh yeah
you can get loose to playboy cardi you
[ __ ] about any kind of tunnel right
Alucard yeah yeah he's fun every time I
put his [ __ ] on the club man go just
really it's a energy thing when he just
like I'm just saying works and I like
yeah that's just yeah yeah I'm a rock
star which beat is this that's that one
woke up
talk something like me talk sexy ha ha
star notices all those hot
I like that beat though this handle is
going do this [ __ ] dude that's it I'm
going to service it
[Music]
alright alright that's a hot beat man
see what terrible interview is that we
could I just be wrong like what the [ __ ]
is going on that's what I do they said
is playing songs that is figuring out
the right there and said hitting the
airman in the club and then using the
vocal process thank you the first ones
to bring the ther many into East Room
yeah oh I gotta be yeah I think we're
the first ones to do it in the DJ said
it's a you know somebody hit me up about
doing an after party for uh for fyf
tonight yeah and even like we can do
$250 why are you for burger fries and
Tony trim I said you know I talk to DJ
burger fries people and the quote is
different 250 bucks that's crazy
not even standard that's crazy yeah I
think you know I think as a negotiator
you just started low just to see if
people are but 250 is an insult like
starting price for us I think people
just be nice career you know you yeah
don't get paint I take 250 I'm a sick as
DJ - I just need a setup that's what I
need I need a cuter I really I just the
iPod DJ I need a hard drive with music
and I'm not I applaud thee Jeremy Rock
good Lane jail for iPod little in I got
I got some little bling Eldorado I got
some little tempo mentioning some my
signature thing with with my DJ sets is
like just uh I'm slamming famous believe
that but yeah but yeah but that's okay
you know
yeah empirical it's like oh boy if it's
like oh boy it's like fine so you got me
I'm gonna be playing the song and [ __ ]
and then it's gonna be like later
yeah and I'm a [ __ ] oh yeah oh yeah slim
say ee damn yeah no my cheat is because
I'm not good at blit I can blend some
stuff but I've learned some couple a
couple cheats to make it mm-hmm so
certain tracks if the tracks have a call
or if they have a part that the crowd
always says at the hook yeah so like
jokingly I'll say to the car you y'all
wanna hear some gangster [ __ ] you
already hear some gangster [ __ ] then
I'll drop in Gwen Stefani holla back
girl
yeah and then on the winners [ __ ] when
they say this [ __ ] is bananas be a na in
it drop the fake this [ __ ] bananas bit
and they're bringing whatever off of
that off of that quiet name don't even
that the master doesn't have them as it
oh that's good we're like that silence
the silence really get some gold cause
if they're [ __ ] it if the parties turned
up and everyone was going crazy and then
and then you drop everything and then
you just hit start hitting with us drop
just be love I've gone from I think I've
gone from mr. funny holla back girl into
like slob on my knob or like ass and
titties three six my just weird [ __ ] or
we be steady my like a good Boozer
that's what I do that's what I've been
playing random [ __ ] I was all over the
population whoa
Oh yo one of my favorite tracks yours is
Hollywood Los Angeles man I believe I've
been listening to that [ __ ] what I'm out
here
well though it's very I like to listen
to music that's very on the nose
[Music]
my footsteps at watch here let me think
I touched on a blood vessel deep so
wrong why I mean so much shadow the
storm in the clip in the back put a
wraps up to this that I'm never looking
back to exact I tacked everything I hold
into it I saw the train on the track
it's a smooth track man I like we ride
to this [ __ ] out here we were in Los
Angeles that whole album man that was on
heavy rotation that's good that's a good
front to back album you could play from
song one to the last song and there's no
there's no burner songs on there
that was weird to to good album about
hearing because I mean I guess this is
the first official dis studio release is
the food yeah this is first our debut
album yeah but you know yeah mixtapes is
like it's a strange thing these days
because you know traditionally a mixtape
would be like you rapping over other
people's beats and [ __ ] like that
whereas internet that was all original
beats you know and you call it a mixtape
right yeah I was considered a mixtape I
don't really with that I really know why
I mean just cuz it was free you know I
mean to me I think that like an album
that's all that is monetary that's why
you know it's not it's not so much
monetary as like maybe the like value
and promotion behind it you know I was
just like house music that I made myself
released myself this is the debut album
because it's the first thing you can get
physically you know you can own and have
buying a store um
jay-z's involves mm-hmm he's a dope guy
yeah and but it's definitely like a it's
it's it's a front-to-back album as well
though you know and like oh he's very
like very much one dark and something
that is really linear and makes
everything makes sense within the world
that I created for this out who's all
involved who some people involved no ID
executive produced album along with
jay-z and my guy Malik Yusef so no I did
a lot of production on their Pharrell
did production and also hit a feature on
there
Williams one of my favorite artists yes
he was on this album the dream my boy
Joey purp Chief Keef Weezer Weezer Todd
dollars excited how did that come about
also unless he said it and besides him
sanded and other conversations I think
that's the only time Chief Keef and
wheeze have been said back and I think
he did it on purpose
what are you can ask this question
already or Garrity you're probably
already answered this a bunch of times
yeah I mean put your go-to album didn't
come out yet it comes out Friday um you
know what's up day or two day today we
drop in this Friday we're done yeah and
it's a Friday
you know Weezer our sample Weezer for
for a beat that I made for the ended up
being the song home wrecker
this one it's my favorite record on the
album and I think I've heard that would
my mom would you play girl breaks it
breaks in the house it is another girl
yeah yeah
so Huizar sampled them for that beat
[Music]
you know I mean and then my boys smoke
Oh Oh No ended up getting in the studio
with the lead singer of Weezer Rivers
Cuomo somehow through like Atlantic
Records or something and so he told me
you know he knew I had sampled them and
this was a good opportunity for me to
come and ask him if he'd clear it and
try to get around some of the you know
other things so I went in there and I
played him the record and he loved it
and and he wanted to jump on the record
man he had like the funniest response to
it too because it's like a pretty hectic
situation you know usually people are
like damned if that really happened that
when I play rivers of song he was like
that's the coolest thing ever
I wish I had a girlfriend like that
though did you think you could you grow
up with Weezer fans yeah yeah there's a
little yeah I love Ouisa man that blue
album me that this is classic - yeah I
got it
I got a few classics you know - that's
tight man yeah dog much success on the
album mm-hmm that command yeah yeah
I'm sure it'll do well today get that
[ __ ] today get it right now right now
debut out in the autobiography today Vic
with autobuyer get it you know what I'm
actually gonna get it because you know
what I've lately I got the streaming
services that me [ __ ] up how I I I
just listened to people [ __ ] right I
used to buy people [ __ ] like no Parker
that's cuz buy that [ __ ] I would just
buy it just because yeah I want people
to buy my [ __ ] right put out something
yeah even if it is like that but there's
my in a value we can call that but then
not extremists I listen to everything
right I don't I haven't bought in my
machine more rare to this are you gonna
have a vinyl yeah I'm a vine yeah that's
how you got to do it yes it is I'll buy
the final I get the vinyl don't steal it
off of the dark room
I got a site I got a site up this I
think it's vic mensa shop where you can
go and you can you know buy like a
science CD or vinyl and all that Oh
nurse and you get to download along with
that there you go
learn tangible yeah tangible album with
albums I like that alright well don't
get that [ __ ] let's close it up this is
good this is get weird and close it out
man I got my said [ __ ] it
[Music]
[Music]
go-go-go canary the time to go to kill
thank you very much vic mensa welcome to
the show would you prefer